now to one of the hot button topics
during the elections the pandemic the
cdc has given its final okay for 28
million grade school children to get
pfizer's covert vaccine some of the
first patients got the shot in hartford
connecticut last night after it was
authorized for kids 5 to 11 years old
their shot is one-third the size of an
adult dose with different color
packaging and a smaller needle our lead
national correspondent david begno is in
lafayette louisiana david good morning
good morning to you the doses are
already here in fact they're being held
in shreveport in baton rouge they just
got to put them on trucks and deliver
them and we expect that to happen first
thing this morning or around lunchtime
i'm very excited i've been waiting for a
very long time for kids like 10 year old
ella conrad the vaccine will be
life-changing she has not seen her
friends in nearly two years not bad girl
because she has an autoimmune disorder
called ulcerative colitis because of
kovid what do you do now i do home
school and i just talk to my friends on
face time because of covid what do you
not do play with my friends and go a lot
of places
stacy conrad is ella's mother how does
this now change things oh normalcy
normalcy we we get to once she's fully
vaccinated
she can go have a sleepover at a
friend's house we can take our life off
of paws
already millions of these pediatric
doses have been packaged and shipped
around the country from pfizer's
distribution center in wisconsin and
they are ready for pediatricians and
pharmacies to use immediately there are
vaccine sites already set up with
separate areas designed to make kids
feel comfortable
the cdc says every million doses given
to children ages 5 to 11 would prevent
about 58 000 cases and 226
hospitalizations in that age group
but there is some hesitancy only 27
percent of parents say they will
vaccinate their kids right away
30 percent say they will definitely not
vaccinate their kids at all and 33
percent say they're going to wait and
see how it's working before making a
decision
consider this there have been nearly 2
million covent infections among kids
ages 5 to 11 and roughly 170 have died
due to covet 19.
which is something to consider as you
decide whether or not the shot is right
for your child